البسيج تبرز كجماعه معارضه للمحتاجين وهي
قوه متطوعه قوامها 700 الف عنصر تشكلت
كامليشيا شبابيه خلال ثوره 79 واصبحت قوه
النسيج شبه العسكريه مؤسسه تتغلغل في
المجتمع الايراني تدافع بشراسه عن جمهوريه
الاسلاميه كنظام سياسي يهيمن عليه المرشد
تدعو الى الحفاظ على قواعد لباس نسائيه
صارمه تدعم التحركات العسكريه الاقليميه
لايران ومن بين المخلصين الاخرين كما
يعرفون الحرس الثوري بالطبع الذي يعد جيشا
قوامه 200 210,000 جندي مكرس لحمايه
الحكومه من الاضطرابات الداخليه اضافه الى
غير ذلك من التهديدات وهي مؤسسه تتبع بشكل
كامل ومباشر لاوامر المرشد عليه اضافه الى
حزب الله الايراني وهي ميليشيا اكثر تطرفا
اسهمت ولا تزال بقمع المحتجين في طول
البلاد وعرض
[موسيقى]